why is piers morgan leaving his morning
show
his morgan it has been announced this
evening is stepping down from good
morning britain this
comes a day after one of the most
explosive shows in
the history since piers has been on it
okay again let's have the names
who did you go to what did they say to
you right i'm sorry i don't believe a
word she says meghan markle
i wouldn't believe it if she read my
weather report it was a very fiery show
tensions were running high and that
spilled over into this morning show
which saw piers morgan walk
off set when he was challenged about his
comments about megan by
the weather person on the show piers at
that point
took his microphone off said he wasn't
standing for this and walked off set
you continued to trash her okay i'm done
with this no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no sorry no
do you know what that's probably you can
trap your mother not mine no no no no no
no no i'm being
sorry absolutely diabolical behavior
hours after that there was an
announcement from itv
saying that after discussions with peers
piers had decided it was time to leave
the show
and itv has no more comment to make
about it
do you think pierce is gone for good and
do you think you could pop up someplace
else
pierce morgan is a bit like the phoenix
who always manages to rise from the
ashes he got
sacked famously in his capacity as
editor of the daily mirror
this is piers morgan tonight he then
went to america and
enjoyed great success on what was the
larry king show and then became piers
morgan tonight
he left that show the real success story
for piers
i think has been good morning britain he
took it from an
average rating to a record rating
in this year him and susanna reid have
proven to be a very popular duo
part of piers's success is his theater
but when it came to meghan markle a lot
of people felt that he was
unnecessarily out to get her out to
destroy
her and harry even friends of his would
pop up on twitter saying
leave them alone mate that's the one
thing that piers morgan
couldn't bring himself to do how
surprised were you it is a great shock
that he's leaving i think it's a great
shame for the program that he's leaving
it's going to be very interesting
to see what happens to those ratings
there's no two ways about it
piers was a huge part of the success of
that show he is a brilliant journalist
he's a brilliant presenter he's like
marmite you love him
or you hate him but he's always got
something interesting to say
i think pierce is leaving which comes at
a time when
he has come heavily under fire on
twitter for being insensitive towards
the couple as megan was
revealed that she was suicidal at one
point
and in which she claimed there were
issues over the
color of archie's skin very very
sensitive topics
topics that needed to be treated
carefully respectfully
he was clearly seen to overstep a line
and perhaps that is
an indicator of the sensitivity of this
story